der Herbst ist da mit sie nael truri s
viicht es wird dünkler im Herz m ganz
schön Kusch will der TR l
[Musik]
Kraft
heen wir über die zarte s vom le über
Melancholie
ut der weltchmerz und auch über abgr der
Depression später denn aber zur
Melancholie so das bitter süße kennst du
das ja ich Ken das mir W mir nichterlich
aber ich so Phase und ich glaube ohne
die Phase hatte ich nicht Philosophie
studieren nicht Philosoph glaub sind der
Moment oder zeige das alles andere ty
das anders Gewicht ja augenöffen die
Moment zum Teil do mal ü Potential V der
melolie dem
Weltschmerz W bekannt Word mit Buch über
Sensibilität das still gei h neues Buch
und das heißt bitter süß wo es genauso
um die doppeltheit Gott V dem Gefühl
also so derruck es tut weh man ist
struhrig und H aber auch so das weiche
schöne zarte und sie macht so das Fest
die Sehnsucht nach dem Gefühl macht sie
fest dass es z.B ein enorme Trend ist
auf Instagram so truriig Bilder oder auf
Spotify s Songs z.B ist ein Hit da
geht's ganz ganz viel Liste und sie eig
SLE hat sie publiziert also interessant
oder also ich B beides interessant ich
glaube auf insta ist v g Trend g die die
heile Welt wo man oft gesehen und das
perfekte und be der Musik Verst ist mega
gut also Musik spricht Herz und triff
das geht von Victor o der schöne Satz
und seit Musik spricht aus was nicht
gesagt werden kann aber worüber zu
schweigen unmöglich ist also GLB ganz
ganz D Weisheit fühlt sich
ja wie Verstand von der Musik z.B finde
ich
auch melancholisch die Musik und
irgendwie schön D mega Phänomen oder
oder immer aber fr was genau melolie und
es gibt ein Song W so spitz dem Kontext
das ist der berühmte Song V Leonard CEN
mit der
[Musik]
drin
allem in riss und genau dem Riss in aus
dem Riss l stell das vor abdunkel rum
und der Riss vom Vorhang seh l ums
heller das heißt es bra Brüch Driss dass
man Licht wiedereht andersh l nicht und
das ist Motto von dem Buch ich vor
zitiert und
genum wir sag erst wenn wir
Brüchigkeit spezifische Form und das
meint das bitter sü
diefigur ja ich Verst Satz stundenang
reden natürlich ich Verst vor allem also
mir hilft Verst Person von
Menschen Freud Freud sozag wenn die mit
i Muster Granze und verleistigenft
Versprecher angstzust und soer du hinter
Fassade von Person und die brü und die
abgrü soer das bringt zu ze zum Verst
wer da ist genau aber vielleicht
erkennnis Moment bra erkennen wenn man
der RT esicht gar nicht so weg von dem
Manuel K gesagt h Text wo erhen Gott
erhen ktis das schlechtthin große also
Ozean riesige Berge würs und er SEAG wie
die Menschen wo sind der Melancholie
sind besonders empfanglich das erhaben
Verst und da G natürlich wie nochal um
transzendentag größer überstiegt wo man
erst erkennen wenn empfanglich s für der
wtschmerz das ist Gide und dank oft dass
das geht ja gar nicht wenn irgendwie
schwer damit überhaupt bis Transzendenz
Glaube und gibt schönes Buch vom fö der
Lob der melanchonie geschrieben und er
seit in das E bitter sü oft nur noch
bitteris will genau sozag die Sehnsucht
ist LEH lauft also es geht die Idee vom
größere vom große Ganze und dann wird
bitter sü bitter und das glaube ich h ja
ist irgendwie Serotoninmangel
dopaminmang so du kan weltbildlich so
wichtigang mit melancholie ist der
genieekult das ist
historisch im 17 Jahrhundert ist der
Begriff der Melancholie Genie Vorbehalt
und natürlich nur im
MA also melancholisch begab gen Frau
natürlich neurotisch oder hysterisch und
der MA wo melancholisch ist interessant
es gibt ein Stich ganz berühmt
Kupferstich vom albrechtü der heiß
Melancholia DAH so einen Engel mit ganz
vielen wissenschaftlichen Instrument
also Wissenschaft wi Begierde ist ganz
ein verknüpft mit der Melancholie und
Dash man schonim Aristoteles W wüss h
melancholische ste will du immer Grenze
Stoß h wieder mit der kipfigur du Grenze
spür aber dur Grenze gerade auch der
Abgrund von der Grenze du mit dem wo du
möchtest darum immer die kipfigur ich
find aber auch schwierig die Kombination
ich Amfang ich find philosophische
Moment aber gleichzeitig würde ja sagen
der N wenn sag die glücklichen sind
neugierig wenn du moment in
bist du um dich selber und soiter und
das selbstmleid und du bist nicht
richtig wach und interessiert an der
Welt und ich glaube man darf nicht
idealisieren od das ist so Wiemer Rus od
Alkohol mit dem Genie zusammenbringt das
stimmt auch überhaupt nicht oder vi
geschafft und sind Grund gegangen dem
oder du projizierst di eig empfinde auf
Wal oder witgenstein die Welt des
glücklichen ist eine andere als das
unglücklichen ich glaub man dank man ich
entdeck jetzt ist die T von der Welt und
die abgründ das Unendliche da got mir
einfach schlecht und ich projizier nach
also fin der zwifel der hab ich
zumindest auch immer dass es alles nur
Projektion istch wenn anders geh wier
ganz anders ja schon Melancholie
Kulturtradition kann man sagen mis gibt
aberis ganz trurig dunkel schwer und
dann wird zu ein Depression und das ist
auch großes Thema der Schwiz jed Z J Z
Set offenbar Depression Lied Statistik
das ist den lustig das H du
schonesprochen H war erlt aber ganz
ander das ist einfach Krankheit ja wo
man muss mit Therapie und Medikament
behandeln und W zum ganz
unterschiedliche Ursache genetische
Ursache da sind kein Expertin ke Experte
und wo man vor allem muss hilf glaub ich
was was wichtig ist aber es geht
natürlich sicher so vericht der Verdacht
wo man eig zit mus hab D mit negative
Gefühl das Tris Teil schnell die
pathologische Ecke rührt oder und se das
nicht
GL pragmatisch zielorientiert und und
wird schnell paologisiert GLB das ist
zumindest mussüber noch Sachen fr
stellen wenn Diagnose zum
zu also mit der pathologisier ist sicher
das Problem
dasan le Psychoanalytiker und
Philosoph ne Buch
zum ganz wesentlich für Mensch s sch
Form von katarsis wie von Reinigung dass
man sehr eng mit e in Kontakt komt mit
abgrü V e selber das ist mega wichtig
das der Musik Z so oder wenn du das los
und de Gefühl noch fü dich irgendwie
besser ist schön die trrige
Musik de bitter sü aber und darum
wirklich aber muss wirklich Unterscheid
zwischen dem wo einfach n so
menschlichen ist und und Gefühl v
und wirkliche Depression was menschlich
ist aber ja aber aber krank nur W
paologisier wir alles pologisier aber es
geht natürlich klar das krankheb von
R Autorin Buch
Romanfigur Depression liedet Sternstunde
und sie sag ganz klar Depression ist
volkskrankit und sie hat das Buch nicht
geschrieben we der Depression sondern
trotz der Depression für sie ist das
ganz wichtig die untersche
will ich depressiv ich sondern obwohl
sie depressiv ist kriegt schrie ein
wahnsinnig schwer ist mit so
krankit vit was Unterschied zwischen
Depression und
TR ich glaube wenn sag git Bild
gut Schriftstellerin
wo W die glasock
sie seit einer stell Depression fühlt
sich wie wenn sie es todsbaby wär unter
Glasglocke das heißt man hat das Gefühl
von total abkapselig gegenüber der Welt
du bist das todsbaby un Glasglocke also
emotionslos auch emotionslos und Wal sch
weg während dem Melancholie gerade
Verbindig zur wtschaftt das heißt ein
ist abkapselig andere Verbindig sogar
noch überis
b das glau
untersched and bist du ein Spezialist
über Humor trotzdem lachen ja ja ich
glaub das das trotzdem finde ich das
hilft mir also W ich sage Situation ist
hoffnungslos aber nicht ernst paradox
oder also du kan trotzdem laor oder fre
mit dem
B Verbrecher morgen wird zum galge
geführt und der murmelt vor sich na ja
Woche V schon mal gut da oder die die
Art V Distanz zu sich selber dass man
sich zum Teil A katapultiert aättige
schwierige tragische peinliche
Situationen Humor das hilft mir sehr ja
und ander ist ablenkig also ich finde
David vorbildphilosoph für mich
schottische Philosoph der wenn im
Zwiefel versinkst undon der schwarmut
den Gang Bard Spiel oder back SPI lenk
dich ab ma anders oder der Schopenhauer
mit S zweackpessimismus sage ich jetzt
mal dass du nicht hö erwarte das Paar
mal besprochen
dasin das ist Freak was auf der
erbarmlich was auf auf der am Rand von
Galaxie istwichtig und kan schei sch
bist und
dan
Tag ich find das ich find es gut extrem
lastend gut so so kann ich aber was ich
nicht ger immer das abchube vom erwart
Management dass du ganzeendwi se ja mus
weniger erwartte das find das finde ich
erlich ganz ehrlich dass man irendwi
nicht mit ke war mit ke
hoffnreichen
nein ja
super mus ein mit de
ja
ja m ganze große Kraft sie wird aber
auch ziemlich vermarktet zur zit es gibt
ganz viel Hashtags sness z.B oder
Melancholie auf Instagram ganz viel so
Bilder es gibt ein Riese
marktmittlerwele wo vielleicht Reaktion
ist auf das ganze positive denk
irgendwie schon Ersatzreligion ist oder
ja also mE es git Israelis Soziologin
glücksdiktat und viele andere Bücher wo
der Trend feststellen ich GLB das ist
ein G Trend oder was du jetzt
beschribsto zum Teil
fastis nicht so GN g so Exhibitionismus
V der V der Wunde vom lieden und so
weiter wo man d immer rechtfertig mit
der enttabuisierig von de ganze
sachepression oder Angstzustand und so
wo sich selber filmet wenn sie zambren
finde ich irgendwie extrem geschmacklos
mü dit ich auch mü die vermark und
irgendwie ja es ist einfach wei nicht
nicht nur das natürlich auch und der
zammenbruch den fast schon wieder schön
inszeniert zeigt und die wirklich
schlimme truh die wirk schlimme
Depression h keine schöne
vermarktigswürdig Sitte ich GLB das ist
das Problem oder dass man ir achlachtet
wo für viele l ganz tragisch ist und
keine schöne vermark würdig s ja und mus
wieder noch bis lat und darstellt das
ist doch Problem und ich glaub das mit
dem glücksdiktat oder oder der Terror
das positiven von der Juliane
schreiberorin das ist viel älter meine
find schon Frankfurter Schul ador
horkeimer Dialektik der Aufklärung
Kapitel Kulturindustrie super also Genie
oder da D und schribt Fan ist ein
Stahlbad oder das die
Vergnügungsindustrie verordnet ist das
Lachen die ganzeit und das wird lache
wird z Instrument wenn richtig im Kopf
hat zum Betrug am Glück wunderbare
formulier hei wir h das L W abhärtet und
das System infüt und und und konturlos
werdet und die glät das man rieiglos
wier funktionieren und beor immer
Konformismus im ganzen das ist schon alt
oder das nicht er 20 J geht mit der
selbstoptimier und L und so aber genau
vor dem Hintergrund ist doch der Trend
zu über und Wichtigkeit von ze so wie
Jonathan macht sch mir genau witig also
ich finde muss dass den schnell seid es
geht glü und jetzt geht quasi wiederum
Überschwang Mark und das war nicht
sondern dass man vorher grundsätzlich me
was machen über die zarte s ven
über das Mens alle MA
ur menschliche erfahr mit
Verlust so nicht die zum Teil vi und
anders Sehnsucht Heim die Gefühl sind do
großartige Gefühle mit dem Verkauf wirk
interessant der das geht ganze Industrie
also ist wahnsinnig am benomen und am
Wachsen das G geht richtig
Gand dem melancholis und B der ne
trendaster es ist nicht so original aber
iche mitaster Angst undit wenn ichbringe
ich das
jetzt stud das wei ich nicht ich w sag
es gibt das plaster für
wagusner und das
ist
über nein aber ich sag das war n zB
Markel sich mit dem bet ja und und das
selfie gemacht oder fotografiert wurde
undaster und n ist
nervner lang und jetzt geht Psychiater
sag tatsächlich wenn stimuliert man
recht gut
erfahremacht hilft das Angst und
Depression
nuras nicht wie
PL Bizeps wie ist es wie lange braucht
das bis es
inkub interessant das ist mega
interessant
Barbara wo man nochmkt tut
manmk ja und das ke Bedütig also weiß es
ist
nichtaster g der welmerz oder das Bill
Weltschmerz es ist so rein of wirkig es
ist nicht ein Satz oder das Mantra oder
Priester se sondern es ist einfach so
Ding wo wenn du der metaphysische
Obdachlosigkeit versinkst und D glaubst
so wie du
Wissenschaft Esoterik ja genau aber
Wissenschaft bin ich für Metaphysik D
bra ke pas immer das alternativ ist bin
ich Metaphysik und Z gad gibt andere ich
noch ein mitbracht sogenann gravity
decky Schwerkraft
Deck okay jetzt mus mal l ich hab mega
geschleppt für dich ja mal da mal
an das ist so
Mikrofon IDE so eine Schw
irgendwiein
Mutter ist wirklich schön das Gewicht
auf Bess wieedy oder besser
das ja Melancholie und das sind
große Welt wo immer alles noch schneller
und lüter wird und wenn i möget e
verzähle V EUR Umgang mit Melancholie
und truh den freum Bruch B Mut aber
schön wenn mit diskutiert und G so zwei
Gespräche ein mit der Ronja von Rönne
über Depression und das elteresprch mit
dem Herbert grünemier über truh wenn
andere Mensche sterbet